I am here with the utterly amazing Natalie Portman
who has written her first children's book,
"Natalie Portman's Fables."
And joining us to talk about it is our resident reviewer,
none other than Jonah Larson.
(audience cheers and claps)
Hi Jonah.
Hi Drew.
I was so excited to see you again
and I'm really excited to review Ms. Portman's book.
So nice to meet you.
I'm so impressed by everything you're doing.
Like this is so incredible.
And thank you so much for taking time with the book.
I'm so happy to meet you.
Thank you, Ms. Portman.
I'm really happy that enjoy my work.
It makes me feel really good,
but I enjoyed and loved your book for a plethora of reasons.
You added a classic and modernized twist
to the fables that everyone knows and loves,
like "The Three Little Pigs."
And I've read the book and then my dad read it to me
and then I read it to my little sister Mercy,
and I loved it more each and every time.
And my favorite story was "The Three Little Pigs."
And it was also my sister's favorite
because she loved that the big bad Wolf
was a girl because usually in fairy tales,
you think that the female character
always needs to be rescued or isn't as strong,
so she thought it was pretty cool
to see that the big, bad Wolf was a girl.
But also I just loved the classic messages
of slowing down and taking your time and doing things right,
and appreciating the things that we sometimes overlook
and we need to be grateful for like our family,
our friends, and also the earth.
And also wanted to really, I can really relate to you
and how you brought that special message
to your mom in the back of your book
because my mom's my favorite too.
And, for all of those reasons,
I'm rating Ms. Portman's fables five out of five
crochet loops.
(Drew claps)
(audience cheers)
Thank you so much.
I am so honored.
I'm like teared up.
This is so meaningful to me that you read it
and took it in that way and processed it.
You're so incredible that you, I don't know,
the way you express yourself is so impressive too.
I have to show you Drew something that's so cool.
Look, it's a Jonah doll.
It looks just like me, we're twins.
And I'm gonna have these on our website as kits.
And, but this one right here, I'm gonna auction
and a 100% of the proceeds are gonna go
to my library in Ethiopia, so I'm super excited.
Well, Jonah, can we put that up on our website
also for your auction?
You would do that?
Thank you so much, Drew.
Thank you so much.
Of course.
That's one of the things that we've connected on,
books and helping others and now you're helping me
help other kids so that makes me really happy.
Jonah, this was our plan all along
to take care of people together
and the love of books being at the forefront.
I love it.
I would be honored.
I will help you.
I will be there by your side, whatever I can do.
This is your endeavor.
I'm just there to shine a light on it.
And Natalie, you and Jonah have something in common
with libraries.
Will you tell us about the important endeavor
that you are embarking on?
Yes, I'm doing the National Library Associations' benefit
coming up, which is so incredible.
Libraries are of course, one of the,
the model places of community,
one of the last places of community
in our country and places where people can gather.
People from all different classes, everybody is welcome.
It's one of the last few public meeting places
and resources of course, cause the books,
the computers, all of the materials
are available to everybody.
And I'm so, so honored to get, to show my respect to them.
I was talking to everyone here just about
how much I love your book, Natalie.
And I like you, Jonah, I read it to my daughter.
So it was really nice to hear these famous fables
that we know so well with a unique spin on it,
such as the way you so beautifully write them, Natalie.
Thank you.
And this is such
an elevated, timeless, beautiful children's book
and it gave me such pleasure reading it as an adult,
but my children just got so much out of it.
So thank you for writing it.
Thank you for putting it out into the world.
Jonah, thank you for reviewing it so thoughtfully.
And Jonah, thank you.
You are such an incredible young human.
You give me so much hope for the future.
Thank you for what you just said.
I have such respect for you, Natalie Portman.
I can't even believe I just heard what you said.
Thank you,
Natalie and Jonah, you're both just so wonderful.
Thank you for letting me be in this space today.
This is like what the world needs is both of your energies,
"Natalie Portman's Fables" is out now.
(upbeat music)